[Music]
this was billed as a huge celebration
the moment that the new civilian
leadership of Sudan was to be announced
and it started as a celebration they
used to turning out in big numbers but
there was a special feeling in the air
thousands upon thousands filled the
streets of the protest square others
cleaned to sign posts all hanging off
bridges it was closer to a rock concert
than a political rally phone lights but
there were already signs that things
weren't right long delays and
conversations between staff speeches
telling the people that the revolution
continued and that the people needed to
stay on the streets others already felt
it as well so you're worried that this
is it looks good but it doesn't now it
seems negotiations between the military
council and their protesters are off
senior players have been warning about
this for some time dr. Matt OE Ibrahim a
human rights specialist is being tipped
as a possible new prime minister if any
agreement can be reached he told me that
negotiations were already in a dangerous
phase it's been an incredible few weeks
of a sort of optimism and it's been
quite a lifting being in the square and
and and meeting youngsters everywhere
talking about it and a fantastic
atmosphere you've said it's a very
dangerous period you know how quickly
are we going to move to the next phase
because it seems that the last few days
it's sort of come to a standstill and
did we lead
a consensus on an executive with a
strong prime minister continue this and
if you don't find that quickly then the
vacuum could create instability yeah
anything can happen and also that could
importantly the council more because
they take military council the
transitional council will start you know
doing executive polls and then it will
be very hard if very difficult for them
to leave this force from the invitees
how this breakdown in trust between the
protesters and the military council
develops isn't clear yet but it isn't
good more and bigger protests are being
planned these are indeed dangerous days
in Sudan mr. Ramji Sky News cartoon